despite recent health problems the duo
is upbeat and focused on ending a career
with an Olympic figure skating gold
medal listen to fall behind we're fully
prepared we've done everything possible
as athletes both physically and mentally
we move across the ice in perfect
harmony I send them to some guy tomorrow
the pair has unveiled a new short
program in hopes of gaining an advantage
over their longtime Russian rivals let's
log in our previous program was classic
figure skating a bit harder to digest
our new program is just as difficult
maybe even more so but it looks looser
and more relaxed by its local policies
the two are unfazed by a press report
alleging us and Russian judges may have
already decided on who will win medals
at sochi the or incidence angle north
wouldn't sing something we're
concentrating on our routine training
and preparation is most important it
will be hard to focus if we spent all
day reading every detail about those
allegations and trying to decipher them
lets viewers containing on Tuesday
they'll begin their last quest for a
gold medal the only major title missing
from their impressive collection